[Music]
when you're a kid there's only one day a
year more special than any other day
and that day is christmas
and we are the magic behind that day
so let's get these [ __ ] kids some
[ __ ] presents
may i present the hardest working man in
snow biz good golly he's jolly our own
santa claus
hey merry christmas whoa
you're on my naughty list
[Music]
good news sir more american kids believe
in you than they do in vaccines or the
holocaust that's great i mean
disheartening for america but great for
us
i'm here from the north pole times have
you decided who will succeed you with
santa claus subtext santa's old and
knocking on death's door [ __ ] you
uh i mean uh good question i'll give it
some serious thought
bye
there have been many santa clauses
throughout history some were loved
others loathe but the position of santa
has mostly been a white man's game
exactly it's [ __ ] crazy things have
got to change my advice to you is
if i die get rid of my porn
i want to be the next santa if this is
your dream you have to at least make
your case [ __ ] you got to get intimate
with that jolly [ __ ] [ __ ] i know
you're right but do you really have to
call me [ __ ] every time you say
something yes [ __ ] because it's
empowering to call you [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go over what we know
santa and the board are all male and all
white
they play golf drink smoke cigars
say things like don't ever marry your
mistress just so you know the women of
the north pole make fun of one of your
dicks have fun wondering whose it is
what i need to learn is how to grow out
with these guys you know shoot the [ __ ]
do shots shoot shots of [ __ ]
she has ideas but can she really be the
face of christmas
i'll be named successor die trying
merry christmas
and to all a kick ass knight
[Music]
bye